as the Gulf Coast cleans up after
hurricane Harvey millions of Americans
are looking ahead to another potential
disaster hurricane Irma was just
upgraded to a category 5 storm it now
packs maximum sustained winds of a
hundred and 75 miles an hour
Florida Governor Detroit a state of
emergency ahead of a potential impact
the storm could strike islands in the
Eastern Caribbean tonight before heading
toward Puerto Rico and the Bahamas
forecasters say
Irma could turn north this weekend
heading for Florida or the Carolinas
Manuel Bojorquez is in Miami with the
latest there man well good morning to
you good morning I'm standing in the
Brickell neighborhood near downtown
Miami and during the storm last month
this area flooded after heavy rains in
fact this is what it looked like here on
August 1st as hurricane Irma may have
its sights set on the US people in
Florida are preparing for the worst
people in South Florida are emptying
store shelves filling grocery carts and
packing their cars with water it's not
good for you it's not good for distress
you have to do it early as early as you
can
Monday hurricane hunters flew through
the storm for the first time as it
gained strength in the Atlantic we'll
know more as the week progresses what
kind of a threat it really poses to to
mime Dade County Carlos Jimenez the
mayor of flood prone miami-dade County
is watching hurricane Irma closely the
storm surge is really the thing that
that kills and those people so that's
what really were worried about storm
surge is when the sea level rises during
intense storms pushing water ashore
leading to flooding a recent study found
Florida has 2.7 million properties at
risk the most in the u.s. Miami Beach
averages around 4 feet above sea level
and fights flooding at high tide on a
regular basis last month
heavy rain turned the city streets into
rivers the anti flood pumps failed
during a power outage the city has
ordered portable backup generators but
mayor Philip Levine warned the pumps may
not be enough these pumps were designed
for normal rain and of course sea level
rise that
we'll be helpful in the event of a storm
but they're not designed for hurricane
Irma now at category 5 but for some
perspective it's been more than 100
years since to category 4 hurricanes
have made landfall in the u.s. in the
same year and with Harvey fresh on
everyone's minds the concern here in
Miami and throughout South Florida is
that if herma makes landfall it could
also be disastrous well thank you very
much